U-Bahn-Linie 2, Hamburg,
Haltestelle Emilienstraße.
Ein Bahnsteig, ein Kiosk
– aber kein gewöhnlicher mit Zeitungen
und Süßigkeiten:
Für die Vorbeikommenden hat der Mann
im Kiosk ein ganz besonderes Angebot.
Schönen guten Morgen!
Guten Morgen!
Was kann man hier denn kaufen?
Hier kann man nichts kaufen,
hier kann man sich zuhören lassen.
Ich bin ganz Ohr, wenn Sie mir ’ne
Geschichte erzählen wollen.
Oder auch nur ’n paar Sätze,
ich nehm’ alles.
Einfach zuhören – das macht neugierig.
Die Leute bleiben stehen an
Christoph Buschs Zuhör-Kiosk in der U-Bahn.
Ich würde mich freuen,
wenn Sie mal vorbeikommen,
da steht auch ’ne … eine
Telefonnummer drauf.
Und Sie schreiben ein Buch?
Das wird dann vielleicht ein Buch, aber
vor allen Dingen hör’ ich erst mal zu.
Sie haben bestimmt was zu erzählen.
Der 71-Jährige ist Drehbuchautor für
das Fernsehen.
Eigentlich hat er den ungewöhnlichen
Ort als Schreibstube gemietet.
Ich hab’ mir vorgestellt,
dass ich hier sitze und schreibe,
und ab und zu
spricht mich mal jemand an.
Oder ich spreche jemanden an
und ich höre ’ne neue Geschichte.
Und zum Schreiben komm’ ich eigentlich
nicht mehr, ich hör’ nur noch zu.
Die meisten Leute, denen Christoph
Busch sein Ohr leiht,
wollen aber nicht vor die Kamera.
Sie erzählen aus ihrer Kindheit,
Episoden oder ihr ganzes Leben.
Und sie freuen sich, dass jemand
für sie da ist.
Die Tatsache, dass man normalerweise
nicht in die U-Bahn-Station geht,
um da zu bleiben,
bedeutet auch, wenn jemand hier hinkommt,
dann ist er extra gekommen
und hat Zeit mitgebracht.
Und da ist …
Hallo, ich hab’ Sie auf dem Zettel.
Sie hatte sich telefonisch angemeldet
und erzählt von ihrer Ehe
mit einem Senegalesen.
Christoph Busch spürt nach: Könnte
das eine spannende Geschichte werden?
Damals bin ich in [den] Senegal
ausgewandert
mit meinem Mann zusammen,
und er war da nicht so überzeugt.
Ich hab’ gesagt: Ey, nein,
das machen wir!
Und: Ich hab’ so viele Ideen.
Und: Das ist ein armes Land, wir
müssen da gute Ideen reinbringen,
das schaffen wir.
Ja?
Hat nicht geklappt. Dreivierteljahr …
… und dann sind Sie zurückgekommen?
Ja, dann sind wir zurückgekommen.
Es war ’ne tolle Erfahrung.
Ich halte schon Ausschau
nach Menschen,
die ich normalerweise so nicht
kennenlernen würde,
also die nicht unbedingt bei mir
zu Hause auf die Party kommen würden
– sogar auch Leute, die mir ’nen
gewissen Respekt einflößen,
oder wo ich denke: Oh, was der wohl
sagt – oder die.
Aber das reizt mich grade.
Ersatz sein für einen Therapeuten oder
Seelsorger will er aber nicht.
Dennoch hört er hier mehr üble Geschichten
als schöne.
Ich sag’ mir immer:
Unglück ist das Gegenteil von Glück.
Und wenn man kein Unglück hat,
weiß man gar nicht, was Glück ist.
Und die Leute, die hier hinkommen,
wollen allermeist aus ihrem Unglück raus.
Und dann ist das hier so ’n kleiner
erster Schritt,
um zu gucken, wie schaffe ich das.
Viele Geschichten gehen
Christoph Busch nahe.
Dann kann er gar nicht anders,
als abends das nach Hause mitzunehmen,
was die anderen ihm dagelassen haben.